hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine torte
bekommt er ein rezept und warum ich
dieses rezept letzte woche bei den topf
kindern gekocht ich mache heute den
upside down kuchen also meinen kuchen
aus der finalen sendung für den ich ein
rosé geld bekommen habe vielleicht nur
kurz so viele denken sich vielleicht
bekommt ihr auch so eine idee also als
die karotten gesehen habe im warenkorb
am eigentlich schon klar sei die suche
machen weil wir an kuchen echte ich für
mein leben gern
ich mache das ziemlich oft sofa zu hause
meistens tanzen kombination nelke und
nelken zimt und mit bisschen müssen mit
drin und dann so ein frischkäse doping
und der kuchen aus der sendung war ganz
anders da habe ich ja dann noch überlegt
eben diese ananas mit rein zu machen und
dann eben daraus so ein upside darum
kuchen zu machen weil dann die
oberfläche nach unten gestürzt wird
in den kuchen werden die ananas stücke
vorher karamellisiert und dann kommt das
später eben drum herum kuchen drauf und
dort habe ich eben noch dazu etwas
orangenschale benutzt und ein paar
pistazien für so ein bisschen quatschen
kuchen
die zutaten jetzt sind für eine 26 cm
springform ich möchte es nicht nur so
einen kleinen kuchen backen
ich möchte auch mal den großen kuchen
probieren denn den kuchen dort habe ich
eigentlich gar nicht probiert
ich habe nur den rohen teig mal probiert
da war lecker aber nachdem da fragt dann
den kuchen gegessen hat haben sich die
zuschauer und darauf gestürzt das
publikum und dann war eigentlich auch
schon weg wir machen das sowieso
bisschen hätte ich mit einer freude
na ja wie gesagt die zutaten sind von
der 26 cm springform wenn ihr auch so
eine kleine kuchen vor machen wollt wie
ich dann nehmt ihr einfach nur das
rezept und teils durch drei ich habe
nämlich auch so gemacht mit nur einem
und dann könnt ihr aber schon zwei
förmlichen damit befüllen als ich halte
die doppelte menge
die halloren anzeigen übrig kurz anzeige
ich jetzt erstmal den zutaten und dann
geht es gleich weiter
für die 26 cm springform braucht ihr
drei eier 150 gramm zucker 135 gramm öl
180 gramm mehl 60 gramm pistazien 225
gramm karotten und eine packung
backpulver dann braucht ihr noch eine
orange von der brauchen wir die
orangenschale ihr braucht eine ananas
etwa zwei esslöffel zucker führt die
ananas und wer möchte kann noch etwas
rum benutzen
ich habe jetzt ganz normalen weißem rum
bevor es losgeht habe ich hier noch
meine bank form mit backpapier ausgelegt
wie das geht habe ich bereits in meinem
business grundrezept video gezeigt der
rand ist nicht eingefettet also nur der
boden jetzt beschichtet ihr könnt die
anderen hast jetzt eben mit zucker
karamellisieren
und mit etwas ruhe denn rum können aber
auch weglassen dann habe ich dort nur
für den geschmack dazu gegeben um den
eben auch so ein bisschen zu verwerten
und in den teig müsst ihr auch keine
ruhe rein geben da reicht die ganze
flüssigkeit komplett aus um wird
irgendwo auf den teig zeigen genommen
weil das nochmal so backt ried mittels
dadurch geht der teig eben noch lockerer
auf aber wie gesagt ihr könnt weißen
raum um nehmen oder ersten einfach weg
bevor es mit dem teig los geht müsst ihr
einmal die ananas vorbereiten
ob eine ananas thrive ist erkennt ja
daran wenn ihr hier aus der mitte die
blätter rauszieht dann kommen die fast
von ganz alleine raus ja so wie hier und
dann wisst ihr dass sie eigentlich ganz
schön süß ist da wenig die ganze ananas
brauchen schneidet jetzt mal von unten
runter
dann schneidet hier
die schale weg
in den anderen aussteller und schneider
habt geht es natürlich besser weiter
unter strom gleich entfernt wird den
werde ich jetzt für den kuchen entfernen
allerdings hat er die meisten vitamine
das heißt wählt den ist nehmen wir die
meisten vitamine zu euch schneide ich
jetzt hier weg und dann schneide ich dir
jetzt so ein schreiben etwa einen
zentimeter dick
schon mal in meine pfanne dies noch aus
die ananas kommt jetzt in pfanne auf
einem heißen herbst
da gebe ich jetzt noch die zwei
esslöffel zucker mit rein und wird es
dann schön karamellisieren lassen
wenn ihr merkt dass sie anders dann
schön karamellisiert und knüpfe sichtbar
auch dann finden dann könnt ihr wie die
walt noch ein schuss rum mit rein geben
schön verkaufen lassen das müsst ihr
aber nicht erkennt auch nur mit zucker
karamellisieren dann den herd
ausschalten und die ananas zur seite
stellen
dann kann nämlich der teig vorbereitet
werden in der zwischenzeit könnt ihr
schon mal die pistazien und die karotten
vorbereiten
das werde ich jetzt einfach im thermomix
machen zuerst gebe ich jetzt die
pistazien in der mixed hat und macht es
auf stufe sechs etwa drei sekunden
sodass ich eben noch stücke drin hab
natürlich mir jetzt wieder hier rein und
kann dann einfach die möhren grob in
stücke teilen und die hier in der
gleichen mix of heben und das mache ich
jetzt auf stufe fünf etwa drei sekunden
so sieht es dann aus die orangenschale
könnt ihr dann ein bisschen reiben
vielleicht verzweifeln
zum rührteig da gebe ich jetzt die eier
lasst die maschine kurz laufen und dann
lasse ich währenddessen den zucker
einrieseln und alles schön weiß schaumig
aufschlagen
die eier noch mit dem zucker verrührt
werden könnt ihr schon mal die backform
vorbereiten und die anna loos hier
eingeben
und zwar wird jetzt einfach hier schön
platziert ist da aufpassen dich noch
bisschen heiß einfach schön anordnen
theoretisch auch im ringen oder hall
bringen hier jetzt darauf anrichten wenn
es eben nicht so in stücke schneidet sie
ich zeige ich das jetzt einfach mal noch
wie ich das mit den ringen mein ich habe
euch jetzt ein paar vorbereitet
so sieht es dann aus wenn ihr eben auch
noch ganz anders stückchen drin habt
wenn die eier dann verrührt sind sehen
sie so aus schönweiß und dick schau mich
dann kommt da jetzt einfach alle zutaten
rein also mehl backpulver karotten und
auch die orangenschale das jetzt schön
früher
wer will kann hier noch ein bisschen rum
reingeben rum dient auch als basis
mittel und lässt den teig nochmals in
die höhe gehen
das kurz einrühren und wenn ihr diesen
orangengeschmack noch etwas hervorheben
wollte einfach noch ein bisschen
orangensaft rein dann nehmt ihr euch
springform gebt den teig vorsichtig über
die anderes und dann habe ich noch die
pistazien genommen und diese darüber
verteilt später für die deko auf und so
werde ich jetzt den kuchen bei 175 grad
etwa eine halbe stunde bis 40 minuten
backen
auf jeden fall weil ich darauf die
stäbchen probe machen ein kuchen ist
jetzt fertig ich habe ihn jetzt aus dem
ofen genommen und lass dir jetzt so in
der form etwa 10 bis 15 minuten abkühlen
und danach kann ich ihnen dann auf die
tortenplatte stürzen nachdem der kuchen
jetzt etwas abgekühlt ist kann ich ihnen
von torgefahr größen vom programm und
damit auch ein upside down kuchen wird
muss jetzt die oberseite nach unten
dafür nehme ich mir jetzt einfach meine
tortenplatte liegt sie schon oben drauf
und dann wird der kuchen einmal
geschätzt jetzt kann ich die springform
abnehmen und das blatt papier
und so sieht dann der fertige upside
down kuchen aus ich gebe jetzt hier
einfach noch so ein paar pistazien drauf
die ich vorhin aufgehoben hatte kuchen
komplett auskühlen
später werde ich ihnen dann mit euch
zusammen anschneiden und hoffe dass er
dann genauso gut schmeckt wie riecht ich
hoffe dass zurzeit gefällt euch ihr
könnt den kuchen natürlich auch ein
bisschen abwandeln millivolt ihr könnt
ja wie gesagt die orangen schon rein
machen oder weglassen ich finde aber
wirklich sehr gut weil es einfach den
kuchen etwas frischer macht denn rum
könnt ihr weg lassen könnten aber auch
drin lassen ganz wie ihr wollt
ich werde in kuchen jetzt zum beispiel
auch mal mit haselnüssen backen oder mit
mandeln
aber ich denke dass die stars sind schon
gut dazu passen weil die einfach ein
kräftiges aroma haben
ich habe den kugeln von euch schon
probiert mir schmeckt wirklich sehr gut
anstatt wirklich sehr saftig allein
durch die ananas und wenn am sonntag
steht ich denke ich geht die
feuchtigkeit aus der anderen ist auch
noch mal mehr in den teig über das den
kuchen finde ich wirklich sehr gut ich
werde ihn jetzt auch öfters machen
ich bin stolz darauf dass sie ein ziegel
bekommen habe und dann wünsche ich viel
spaß beim nachhaken wird durch eine
schöne zeit ich würde mich freuen wenn
ihr mehr fotos auf meine pinnwand posten
wenn ihr den kuchen nach macht und stand
freue ich mich aufs nächste mal
ich werde natürlich auch die anderen
rezepte nach einer gewissen zeit
veröffentlichen auch die man von spätzle
knöpfle und die kartoffeln den anderen
kuchen also kommt jetzt alles meter zeit
ist damit ihr viel spaß dabei und bis
zum nächsten mal tschüss